الاعتقال الاداري اجراء تقول المنظمات
الحقوقيه ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يلجا من
خلاله الاعتقال المدنيين الفلسطينيين دون
تهمه محدده ودون محاكمه مما يحرم المعتقل
ومحاميه من معرفه اسباب الاعتقال ويؤدي
غالبا الى تجديد امر الاعتقال الاداري
بحقه لمرات متتاليه حسب نادي الاسير
الفلسطيني فان السلطات الاحتلال استخدمت
هذه السياسه بشكل متصاعد منذ السنوات
الاولى الاحتلالها الضفه الغربيه وقطاع
غزه عام 67
سجلت الى حدود عام 2014 اكثر من 50 الف
حاله اعتقال اداري من بين اكثر من 800 الف
حاله اعتقال حسب معطيات وزاره شؤون الاسرى
وخلال سنوات الانتفاضه الاولى صدر نحو
19000 امر اعتقال وكان العدد مشابها
تقريبا خلال سنوات الانتفاضه الثانيه شهد
عام 2022 العديد من التحولات على الصعيد
واقعي عمليات الاعتقال وفق نادي الفلسطيني
اصدر الاحتلال اكثر من 2400 امر اعتقال
اداري العمل الماضي وبقي منهم نحو 850
رهن الاعتقال الاداري وهو الاعلى منذ اكثر
من عشر سنوات بين هؤلاء 19 طفلا تعرضوا
للاعتقال الاداري وبقي منهم سبعه اطفال
رهن الاعتقال الاداري واسيرتان كما تنتهج
دوله الاحتلال سياسه الاعتقال الاداري
للاسرى السابقين فقد حولت العام الماضي
فقط 43 مقدسيه للاعتقال الاداري علما انها
جددت لبعض الاسهل الاعتقال الاداري اكثر
من مره ومع امعاني قوات الاحتلال فاعتقال
المزيد من الفلسطينيين اداريا اضطر الاسرى
الى القيام بخطوات نظاليه عده منها مقاطعه
المحاكم العسكريه الاسرائيليه والاضراب عن
الطعام في عام 2022 خاض قرابه 75 اسيرا
عده معارك للامعاء الخاويه احتجاجا على
عده اجراءات تعسفيه ومعظمها كانت اضرابات
ضد الاعتقال الادا ري ومن اطوالها اضراب
المعتقل خليل عواوده الذي استمر لمده 172
يوما وتعمد الاحتلال توجيه تهمه جديده
الله للاستمرار باعتقاله والتنصل من اتفاق
سابق معك
[موسيقى]